you love Andy I love Andy somebody asked
me the other day how long have you known
Andy and because I've known so many of
my friends for so long I keep thinking
he's my new friend but then I recalled
oh wait I was pregnant I was really I
had terrible morning sickness and then
before I was like oh no he's not he's my
new friend but it's we're working on
25 26 years now it's a real friendship
and we've come a long way in the
beginning we kept bumping into one
another and we had mutual friends but it
wasn't a friendship that was easy do you
know like when you have somebody new in
your life and you're drawn to them but
you wouldn't ask them out
alone but then eventually we were going
to the theater he would come to the
theater with me I drag him to a theater
or a restaurant Deep in Chinatown that
he'd try to understand but those are
those kind of experiences that
eventually you're in a room with them
and you don't have to talk and he's that
friend that's real you know and it just
changes I was talking to Andy last week
about this on the air I mean he told me
he's building a house next door to yours
I said you know what leave the woman
alone wait for her to invite you over I
mean don't I don't know I said Andy what
are you standing on the deck waiting to
see if Sarah's out there and then you
know like I could see him sitting out
there all day it's thrilling and my
daughter is going to babysit for Ben oh
wow she already has actually yeah no
it's not a an annoyance it's like a kind
of a bonus like some kind of wonderful
thing that happened yeah I don't know I
wouldn't do well with a famous person in
my you know because I'm so [__] up
that I have to be the most I feel like
you're not I have to be the most famous
person like I'll trust me when I tell
you I'm [__] up you know what I mean
like like I was walking uh Jimmy Kimmel
would come over my house and we'll go
for a walk or something always
throughout the years that I knew Jimmy
early on there was no question when I
was walking with him everyone came up to
me and wanted him to talk with me and we
carry on him on a picture with me and I
loved it because let him let this guy
sit and watch my fame and then Jimmy
show caught on and he's on late night
time and all of a sudden walking with
him and people are hey Jimmy and I was
like oh boy oh I gotta get rid of this
guy I want him out of my life I'm not
walking around with him no
seriously I mean Sarah I I don't want it
I love you but
you but